les élections départementales sont
programmées les dimanches 22 et 29 mars
si vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre
physiquement dans votre bureau de vote à
ces dates il existe le vote par
procuration
le principe une personne appelée le
mandant désigne un mandataire qui votera
à sa place la procédure a été simplifiée
depuis l'année dernière donc il suffit
de se rendre au commissariat ou à la
gendarmerie avec donc une pièce
d'identité et le cerfa donc cerfacs on
peut remplir en ligne sur internet ou
directement sur place au commissariat ou
la gendarmerie
donc cette personne donc le mandant
donne procuration à une personne qui est
le mandataire et ce mandataire donc ça
peut être n'importe quelle personne
inscrits sur les listes électorales et
domicilié sur la même commune que le
mandant ça peut être n'importe qui ça
peut être un collègue un voisin un ami à
condition que cette personne qui va
voter pour vous soient inscrits sur les
listes électorales il faut à la
procédure validée par les services de la
mairie le mandataire peut officiellement
voter le jour du scrutin la personne le
mandataire donc arrivée au bureau de
vote avec sa pièce d'identité sa carte
d'électeur donc elle précise dans le
bureau de vote qu'elle va voter donc
pour quelqu'un donc ensuite dans les
bureaux de vote il ya des vérités des
étapes de vérification pour voir qu'on a
bien cette procuration et que les noms
coïncident et ensuite la personne peut
voter
à la place de quelqu'un d'autre au total
5 à 8 % des personnes inscrites sur les
listes électorales devraient voter par
procuration pour les élections
départementales cette année ça
fonctionne très très bien on a
énormément de procuration ce soit donc
pour les élections municipales de 2014
et pour cette année on en a quand même
de plus en plus ça si vous n'avez pas
encore fait votre demande de procuration
pas de panique vous pouvez envoyer les
documents jusqu'à la veille du scrutin
toutefois les responsables de l'état
civil aux commandes de remplir votre
procuration 3 à 5 jours avant pour
pouvoir traiter l'ensemble des demandes